y'a jeff qui va nous rejoindre jeff il a
participé à la 14e saison de koh lanta
en malaisie 2015 il a participé à
l'émission pendant 29 jours il était
dans l'équipe des rouges était un des
plus performants
jeff on connaît son tempérament regardez
il sera juste après parce que lui aussi
il a des choses à nous dire c'est parti
on a le real de madrid on perd contre
dijon comme ailleurs
je suis perdue contre je ne sais pas
j'avais mangé les gars m'a jamais manger
tes cris pourquoi ils me réveillent
si je reviens je vous défends sa trompe
[Musique]
jade de koh lanta nous d'arriver à une
amie qui colle aux jets
merci d'être là un très grand aventurier
jeff de koh lanta et jeff avant tout une
question à vous poser en 2015 on a voulu
vous faire venir sur le plateau
oui parce que j'étais très très fan de
vous merci pourquoi vous n'êtes pas venu
et là ça ça ça en avait l'air
qu'est ce qui sépare le premier annoncé
sur le plateau gt en folie zeitouni
collègues ils m'appellent
malheureusement j'ai eu un petit appel
de la part de la prod
j'ai dû vous sortir le mensonge normal
pour justifier mon absence et c'est je
pense ce qui motive beaucoup de
candidats de koh lanta que vous invitez
ouais mais lpf et un blockhaus quoi il
est donc la production a dit vous
n'allez pas ailleurs on va balancer un
peu le truc parce que j'en ai un peu
marre de cette hypocrisie alpert bloquer
tout ça uniquement parce que des
personnages bien comme ce rds d'autres
vous avez une joute verbale
quand même assez c'est aussi long oui
mais après il y en a qui aiment que
l'ontarien acc espa oui ils ont seifert
pour vous ici ils ont ils ont eu peur
donc je ne suis plus en contre avec
alpes et donc balancé en émotions
alors
il est énorme alors jesse donc je vous
avais fait koh lanta vous étiez un très
bonne aventurier et aujourd'hui vous
êtes blacklisté de l'émission pour avoir
donc participer à la saison 8 des anges
en 2016 voilà c'est une autre production
un coup ne pourrait pas participer à la
version all star de koh lanta
et ça ça vous ça nous fait de la peine
bien sûr bien sûr je suis black-listé
surtout que là forcément judicieux bon
on va être très sincère quand j'ai signé
avec les orges on m'a dit bon tu fais ça
tu est cramé ouais je comprends bien sûr
apprécié la façon dont j'ai été un petit
peu considéré comme un pestiféré d'avoir
sur cet écran il y avait encore mon
crâne d'oeuf c'est vous qui disiez way
jeff est blacklisté lalami collègues qui
m'appelle c'est chaud quand même je
dirais oui voilà donc et donc alors vous
avez posté un message sur twitter
oui je suis black-listé je ne suis pas
au casting de cette aventure incroyable
que koh lanta car j'ai fait un programme
qui ne me correspondait pas sur une
chaîne qui ne me correspondait pas j'ai
pris de l'argent mais j'ai payé le prix
fort moi je vous dis je peux comprendre
la production qui vous disent si vous
avez été les ans je n'ai pas revenir ag
/ à kolontar bière en plus c'était
facile encore ces deux chaînes
différentes mais aimez vous pourrez vous
l'acceptez pas on peux me considérer
comme un rageux parce que je veux pas le
ce qui me dérange énormément c'est que
j'ai fait deux mois chez les anges
ouais d'accord c'est normal pas la même
problématique en un accord - contre
quand cela mon pronostic bien sûr il n'y
aucune preuve mais on va dire que c'est
un pronostic
vous reprenez au casting des personnes
qui ont fait 1 2 jours en mocassins de
luxe mais des personnes qui ont mangé
dans la glacière qui sont fait avoir par
la prod
donc il ya des alors qu'ils ne
représentent rien volé dintrich heures
comme metroid
il ya dès lors m il ya des trios nombre
lanta est un mec après six mois ferme
dont les dossiers ont été balancés il a
donné donc un casier judiciaire il faut
non pas la prod est juste parce que
clairement il a des rapports sont un peu
proche avec cette nation la prod hop le
casier du ceri fini vierge c'est à dire
que vaut mieux au niveau de l'éthique
dalpé et pour le programme de koh lanta
vaut mieux faire six mois ferme que deux
mois dans les anges très grave ce que
vous dites est encore mal organisations
je les assume et on comprend la muse les
assume
j'ai pas dis dedans je les assume et
s'il ya une personne qui considère que
je mens je l'atteins en face de moi vous
dites que des gens qui ont un casier
judiciaire vont faire koh lanta et vont
vous à bloquer donc pour vous et vous
avez un secret pour personne
personne personne ne doit faire ni les
voodoo ni les autres alors personne
voilà nommé
la première question que j'ai jeff oui
monsieur lord je suis super fâché contre
vous parce que vous êtes un bel
hypocrite
souvenez vous êtes sans vous faisiez koh
lanta j'arrêtais pas de dire que c'était
truqué pipeauté vous me rétorquer sur
les réseaux sociaux mais arrête et de la
montre alors maintenant des années après
vous le ballon c'est tout ça parce que
vous êtes m parce que vous êtes amer de
ne pas faire le all-star vous balancer
mais il ya plein d'autres gens qui font
pas le lien que vous auriez dû parler
avant franches mais pourquoi parce que
notre déception mais je te répondre à
monsieur d'erdf est ce que j'ai déjà dit
je critique la production de koh lanta
koh lanta est le plus beau programme la
production c'est autre chose le
programme il n'y a aucune triche
michel danesse vouera droit dans les
yeux aussi dans ma saison et aucune
triche
ok c'était pas ma saison et je vous le
dis on s'attaque au film ah merde c'est
pas ma saison jeff logis moi je moi
voilà l'adversaire on va la retrouver
alizée a crié l'analyse est là qu est ce
qui vous choque beaucoup plus oui c'est
que ce que vous autres à nous dire c'est
que finalement si vous avez pris dans la
saison de koh lanta all stars et bien
finalement les six mois de prison les
tricheries et tout ça vous vous seriez
assis dessus ça vous choquer pas du tout
dans ça vous choque uniquement parce que
du coup vous n'êtes pas dedans et shanxi
a dit je me serais quand même si vous
n'en avez rien vu rien n'est pas quitter
direct qu'est ce que vous en savez
n'avons le saura jamais mais vous aurez
pris dans leur retard vous auriez dit
non ouais si vous mettez les stars est
ce que vous direz oui comme ça pourri
que je perde
voilà de quoi mais pour y revoir mais
c'est pas que ça mais ça chez moi c'est
juste parce qu'un mec a été pris alors
que par rapport à son calvaire alors que
à la base on doit donner 15 judiciaire
vierge a compris on a encore pris jeff
en train de dire juste que si vous avez
de près dans l'émission vous aurez
fermer les yeux sur des trucs
dégueulasses ou pas mais je le maire de
genève que oui vous orienter deux ans je
voyais sur l'île mais j'aurais pas su
parce que je n'aurais pas eu mon que
celui-ci est prêt soit moi les mecs moi
j'ai rien compris
en résumé diète pourquoi vous n'avez pas
d'histoire qu'est ce que vous voulez
dénoncer ce qu'on m'avait invitée ce
qu'on vous a interdit de venir ici
clairement à l'époque donc voilà bien
sûr il ya donc la production vous
interdit de venir ici j'ai eu écho quand
même que vous parlez pas manière fois
que ouais c'est d'éviter les arts on
vous en parlera tout alors oui mais elle
est où le confirme d'accord parce qu'ils
ont peur de me fait de leurs mauvais cas
d'accord ils ont peur de leurs moyens du
bord de mer dette
mais bien sûr qu'ils ont peur eh ben le
truc c'est que quand même on a tous ces
de tous et la joute verbale
voilà on se détendant après et dont est
ce que vous vous êtes amer de ne pas
faire koh lanta all stars vous nous
confirmer qu'il ya aucune triche dans
koh lanta jamais confirme je vous
confirme que dans ma saison de votre
saison la mer dès hier matin là il va
pas mal et une autre raison aucune
triche
voilà bien ou alors le seul truc qui a
eu un franc mais voilà un sport est
transparent c'est complètement
indépendant de la production on appelle
ça des faux abandon athmane mais ça
c'est vrai par exemple je veux pas vous
voir
d'accord je veux pas vous voir c'est
très bien je vais je vais voter contre
vous on est d'accord sauf que c'est offs
à marseille normal il va me dire un
petit coin frérot je suis pas bien
bottes pour moi je veux sortir je veux
sortir mais il faut pas d'accord ce que
je vais faire qu'est-ce que je vais
faire fuir mais c'est chaud parce que je
vous aurais pu sortir mais j'ai voté
pour lui et je vais vous laisser
mais la production et s'en mord les
doigts parce que ça nique le jeu carmin
d'accord donc c'est mam est clairement
ça je vous le dis clairement il n'y a
aucune aucune tricherie monde et sans
galère pendant 30 jours
et tout le reste mais vraiment personne
ne mange personnellement je vraiment
personnellement je vais l'aider dans son
travail en technique il ya c'est
vraiment une émission c'est une vraie
rigueur et ya aucune triche vraiment
rien n'assure une il s'est fait en
scénario
[Rires]